good afternoon everyone and thank you
all for being here um this is a special
committee committee on Co response
efficacy uh I would start like to start
with the pledge and Alicia would you
lead us in that
please aliance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you Alicia um I would like to
take a moment just to read what the
mission of this committee is this
bipartisan committee is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19
pandemic the committee will function in
a
science-based fact-f finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining there
too areas of particular Focus will
include the administration of federal
guidance acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of the emergency use
authorization vaccination
efforts a report will be issued
outlining the committee's findings and
the impact on New Hampshire now it
doesn't State when our report is due but
as we are elected officials uh the
normal date is usually November 1st of
the current year 2020
4 um and I would like to welcome
everyone here I would like everyone to
maybe
um I'd like to discuss with everyone
about the the meeting time and the
dates um to see uh everyone's
availability and my thought is that we
would do this in chronological order but
I am open to suggestions on how the
committee would like to proceed so if
anyone has any thoughts um and uh the
normal date would be Fridays at the same
time go
ahead
representative
gr thank you um I spoke with the other
Representatives who could not be here
and Friday is a good day for us we would
prefer the morning because some of us
have committee meetings in the afternoon
so if we could meet in the morning that
would be best for us if that would work
for for at least five of
us uh how does the rest does that work
for the rest of the committee Yuri
represent of uh beler pitz and could you
let me
know I I think that would be okay we're
on education together so typically we
don't have Fridays we
ask uh uh for me afternoon sa better but
I can be flexible if the rest of
committee needs money I can be amendable
to meet on Friday
[Music]
mornings yeah I'm I'm actually I would
love Friday mornings uh the earlier the
better um for me and I just wanted to
make sure that if there's any like today
I had to testify um on a bill so that if
any of us have you know if there is
something with a another Comm that we
run out and can come back but I would I
would love to do mornings as well
okay so hearing that Friday mornings
would work best uh would uh 9:00 a.m.
start time be amendable to folks that
would give us 9 to approximately
noon
okay um so uh for the future we'll plan
on Friday meet morning meetings starting
at 9:00
a.m. I know that we are coming up
against a session break however um
with the amount of
information that this committee needs to
get through I'm wondering if everyone is
available on February
22nd and March
1st well I think March 1 is the end of
the break right it is yes so I don't
think any um I know that the five people
that I representing right now are not
available because they're all some of
them are going
away
my kids want me to go away I don't know
if we're going to go away or not but if
we're here I'll come
so uh February 22nd would be the start
of the break uh is that amendable to
everyone I was hoping to sneak away but
um I will this takes priority so I will
not sneak away if we're going to meet if
we aren't going to meet I'm going to
sneak
away yeah F Friday February
23rd
and March 1 uh works for
me represent gr did you yes I are we
meeting once a month every other like
are we going to meet twice a month
because if we do that maybe we say that
we're no we're going to be meeting every
Friday oh well okay that's not going to
be um that that was the car on other on
Fridays and so and Karen eel has other
okay and and that's why I was thinking
some afternoons because I know some
people have meetings in the
mornings um so I wasn't sure but we can
uh I will reach out with um the rest of
the committee and find out and let
everyone know what everyone where
everyone
stands can we be flexible on our Fridays
as far as mornings or afternoons based
on the committee schedule I think that
would be
prudent yeah I agree the flexibility of
it I'd be happy to try to um put
everybody all the representatives in
kind of like one column and then you
know especially with commitments and
Friday and just to do a tally I can do
that to see where things come and then
when we're placing dates so you know um
I'll do
that
um earlier today we received a email
from
DHHS uh Trish is here and um to to tell
us that they were already working on a
report a pretty comprehensive report um
I'm not sure if everyone had a chance to
look at that um and I was just wondering
if uh anyone would mind if I had her
come up and kind of speak to what that
report would entail and tell us a little
bit about it does anyone
object
okay good afternoon for the record my
name is Patricia Tilly I am an associate
commissioner at the department for
Health and Human Services um of note uh
for much of the pandemic I was also the
director of Public Health I am new to my
role as associate commissioner public
health is still within my book of
business though so um I have some
experience we were just talking about uh
March 2020 uh so I have been there
throughout the entire time I have an
incredible team as you as many of you
know um as you go further into your
committee I'm I hope that you'll take
the opportunity to hear from them the
folks that are absolutely experts in
those fields I was saying you don't want
me to get here and talk about the
laboratory and the panther machines and
all of that like we've got great people
who can do that so speaking towards this
after Action Report called an
a um the governor was very interested in
ensuring that we had a complete record
of what the response was what the
challenges were what the strengths were
and how the state came together and so
he charged Homeland Security and
Emergency Management HSM to work with a
vendor with a contractor to develop that
after action report it is well underway
um it it will be completed in June of
this year we have there is a draft right
now that isn't ready for public vetting
quite yet they're just getting in the
informations there was a series of um uh
interviews and surveys that were
crosscutting across many many different
stakeholder groups um as I noted in the
email this morning it is far beyond just
the health and medical components of the
um of the response and really takes a
look at um our overall level of
preparedness to be begin with the
command structure the unified command
structure that was based out of the
state emergency Operation Center our
Communications our how we made decisions
and what kind of compliance we had which
I know is something of interest to this
committee the financial management not
only of specific I know you there is
some um interest around vaccine but
overall around the financial management
of all of the covid funds that came into
the state of course the health and
medical components which would include
both the testing um the policies vaccine
eventually Therapeutics all of those
components come together and so it's
taking a look at that um looking at how
we manage the logistics our public
private Partnerships and public
information in that public private
Partnerships one of the things that I'm
very proud of was the governor had stood
up something called the governor's
reopening task force that really worked
in those early days to hear from
Community from industry to understand
what it would take to reopen and reopen
in a way that was safe for their staff
and their customers so that's the high
Lev overview of what that after action
report is um it's underway it won't be
done until the beginning till June um
but I'm sure that there are pieces of it
that we can certainly start exploring
within this committee as well so as not
to duplicate
work does anyone have any
questions please thank you um Miss
Tilly what how was I'm I'm trying to I
spoke with members of my community
before today and some of them had wanted
to come and testify before the committee
and I think it would be important to
have people from New Hampshire who were
involved with municipalities or U Public
Utilities such or Public Safety um
organizations come and speak with us and
my well was the link between your
activity and what municipalities were
doing oh that's an excellent question
thank you representative groda so um we
worked closely um we being the
Department of Health and Human Services
worked very closely under this what was
called the unified command structure
that was based at the state emergency
Operation Center and within that entity
that was the emergency group that was
pulled together and so it had
representatives from all of the most
Major Impact um state agencies so
everything from Health and Human
Services to economic supports to uh
transportation and hsem homeland
security has a special relationship with
the municipalities and so there was a
direct messaging to the municipalities
through that unified command structure
you know for example they had early it
was more than this but sort of at once
we got into a steady Cadence there were
once a week calls with the
municipalities from Homeland Security to
talk about what the changing guidelines
were again you know all of us may have
memories of that time when everything
shut down how do we reopen restaurants
shut down how do you reopen that what
was the role of a a health officer in a
community um even down to how do you
safely plow the roads when um you need
to might have like two guys in a truck
so like those were the breath of um
things that were discussed but typically
most of the um messaging came from
Homeland Security through those channels
um out to the
municipalities thank you so M mam chair
I would imagine that we'd want to hear
about that because I know for our own
town um we are part of the SE Coast
Community and we have a lot of state
parks and so the commissioner of state
parks was in contact with us I think it
was every week on Friday mornings
actually to talk about what was going on
and what the protocols were going to be
for people to park because it was
outside right it was available to the
public yes I I mean my recollection of
that time as well especially early in
2020 was um the the state parks
commissioner at the time was actually on
that reopening task force and so he was
engaged right away going how do we
reopen safely again you know especially
that first summer everybody Public
Health included wanted people to get
outside um I think we can all remember
the cars parked up on 93 outside of
Franconia Notch which was a safety
hazard but but it was a reflection of
the fact that we all everyone was
encouraging everyone to get outside for
your physical health for your mental
health for every reason um and so there
was communication that way I'll also
note that as part of that unified
command there was a leadership call
every morning at 8:15 in the morning
with um from the governor's office down
to the highest levels of of state
agencies so the central um
Communications well never perfect no one
can ever look back in an emergency and
say the communications were great all
the time time um there was a concerted
effort to make sure left hand knew what
right hand was doing throughout lots of
things we learned through that process
but that certainly was the um plan going
through and it evolved as time went
on represent
Pa thank you Madame chair and thank you
for taking my question I I wonder day
about uh after Action Report uh thank
you for working on it and I understand
that
uh it's about to be ready in June uh but
as our committee is
trying um to get some uh wisdom from it
hopefully earlier is there any chance
like you can provide the committee with
some early findings from that report or
something sure so thank you very much
for that question so as I said Homeland
Security are the the the folks managing
it right now so we'll work closely with
director buckton understand what we can
share what we can't share certainly sort
of probably you know I will go out on a
a limb and say there's probably some
broad Strokes that can be shared right
now I don't know that they're ready to
share a draft at this moment um because
it's still actively being written but I
think there are some broad Strokes
learnings that are certainly um
appropriate as your committee goes on
and meets but again the final document
will not be available till
June and if you indulge me for another
question it's not something we were
planning to go deep into today but since
you
mention uh as far as I understood your
words you were talking about people who
were going hiking and that uh everyone
was encouraging people to go outside can
you a little bit expand on it
because uh the reason I'm asking it's
not something that I remember so is it
your recollection that it was a public
policy advice for people to go outside
sure so thank you um you know I know
that the governor was very encouraging
of people to use outdoor spaces at that
time we wanted to make sure that
everybody could get out and about um you
know I I I don't know that it was a
written policy anywhere but it certainly
was encouraged for people to get outside
um during those especially summer 2020
and of course from then I would not have
I've been a I'm not a former uh director
of Public Health without saying that
getting outside is always healthy for
you you should everyone should get
outside and get their exercise every day
that's my public health message of the
day um but even especially then when um
there were so many unknowns about indoor
spaces we knew that outdoor spaces were
certainly better for um folks to be able
to be out and about um you know there
were always questions about you know
masking and I know that this committee
will probably take on some of those
masking questions early on about the
appropriateness of that and where that
was appropriate and the evolution of our
understanding of Max masking and um even
again thinking about it in a
chronological way when we simply did not
have supply chain in you know March or
spring of 2020 and how that changed over
time so Madam chair as I'm thinking
about this and listening to director
Tilly and listening to um representative
Poff I'm wondering if I I if we I
wondering if we put together
a list of of items that we want to talk
about because unless we can communicate
that to the public no one's going to
know what we're talking about at our
particular meetings and so to encourage
public input what are your plans on
doing that um well uh representative
Bel I was going to wait but this is
actually a perfect time to interject
with a a comment I was going to make on
the
proposed path forward um I I I like
certain ideas about the chronological
approach but there's a certain amount of
concern that I have if we work
chronologically one of those big
concerns is that because we have limited
space to get everything done we may
either get bogged down in any particular
area for too long or the alternative
because we're so trying to re you know
recognize and we have limited time we
might move too fast over certain periods
of time so I was going to recommend if
we would take it under consideration
more of a topical based approach where
we identified um the sort of segments of
what we're looking at and attacked it
from that angle so for instance we could
have a big topic such as
um the um treatment protocols that were
prolongated and then underneath that
there could be subcategories of okay we
could look at early treatment protocols
late treatment
protocols ventilators vaccines and sort
of instead of going from the beginning
forward uh it's just my my my belief
that it would be a little bit easier to
organize in that
manner uh thank you for that I I
agree and so my thought and that's why
we're having this meeting today is so
that we can all discuss the best Best
Way
Forward oh thank you I'm sorry um the
the best way forward would be to
um I guess start at the beginning but
like we're going to find out immediately
that one of the first one of the
protocols was is we shut
down and that the next thing was masking
uh those were two early on protocols
that happen chronologic in a
chronological order and I think if we
look at that
you'll find that when we did shut down
then we were encouraging the Open Spaces
uh which brings in uh the commissioner
with the state parks uh then then we'll
get into as we go on further a little
bit further down we'll see that where
the protocol started coming in uh with
the hospitals and the nursing homes and
things like that but like I said the
reason for today's meeting is to
discuss the path forward um and how we
where where do we want to start first
and I am
open so I'm wondering whether or not I'm
so sorry I'm wondering whether or not we
might have start might want to start
with the small picture because the small
picture is where like for example I'm
thinking of municipalities
municipalities took their direction from
Homeland Security so as a result of
their direction from Homeland Securities
what are the things that they did What
Would recommend be done again and what
didn't work so we have some um what's
the word I'm looking for we have some um
experience on exactly what happened to
the to on on our constituent level
because that is who we represent right
so and then including that um for
example this morning I I was I was I
attended a um a school event and I spoke
with the school psychologist and I said
to her what are what are the things that
are now that you um are experiencing as
a school psychologist so you know um
there are things that we can learn from
what what our constituents experienced
so that we know what God forbid this
ever happens again how we what are the
things that we're useful and what are
the things that we're not useful does
that make sense I mean I'm just trying
to think I I know that my database are
my constituents right that's where I'm
going to
go AB absolutely um I do think that it
may be useful and I'll to have uh
director buckon in here to talk about
how he uh communicated with because
obviously he was at the top and
everything was trickling down and it
would be interesting to see where he was
taking his direction from and how
everything was filtering down
um and then from that we can get into
the
municipalities uh the schools and how it
affects um the our citizenry our
constituents um any thoughts on
that
represent yeah I was I was thinking if
we were kind of topical but one of the
aspects of each topic would be the
municip ality for instance education
might be a topic but we would have how
it affected the schools how it affected
the parents how you know all of those
people so that would be a topic but it
would include and when we do a topic we
could ask residents of the state to come
in and speak to us if that's what we
wanted to do or I don't know that might
become many hours I um I think or at
least right to us right I think it's
essential that the people have a right
to come here and be heard and discuss um
what they experienced people experienc
different things um and I think it's
important as Representatives that we
hear all sides of the issue um so that
we can get a better understanding um of
how people were actually
affected
Penza I have a question for you um Mrs
Tilly thank you okay so my question in
regards with this kind of um report that
is you said is due in June yes so this
is this is coming from you're saying the
executive branch it is coming from
Homeland Security emergency management
so from the Department of Safety
executive
branch okay so the feds or the state the
state okay
um so this is because I when I read your
email I guess I thought it was coming on
on the federal side not on the state
side so this is going to be exactly
specific to New Hampshire it is 100%
about New Hampshire certainly Federal
guidance and federal inputs are part of
that um but it is from a New Hampshire
perspective um on the New Hampshire
specific response Okay so if um we're
going to ask for some some information
one of the biggest things that um I
would like is to is to literally have um
kind of spelled out you know all the way
down from the dime to the nickel to the
penny um for the money that has um come
in and run through whether it be uh you
know through cares through all of that
um um through the executive Council
federal state whatever I'd love all of
that Ian is that something that you guys
will be working on um because that's one
thing that I could give you guys in
advance that we would like to have I
know thank you very much for that
question um that's a tremendous
undertaking as you can as I'm sure you
appreciate um and so certainly I will
bring that back for all of the state
agencies because as you know money came
in from every corner um and money came
into each of the state agencies in
different ways money came directly
certainly our we certainly know about
the Gopher um that has been managing
that set of arpa money um and I can't my
brain is freezing for me of what uh arpa
stands for but it that is a huge pile of
that money and so I think to the degree
to which we can provide that information
you know um we certainly have anything
that was after the uh em the state
emergency certainly went through
governor and Council so there is all
public record it came in through fiscal
committee you know during the actual
State emergency um th there was
information provided to um those
entities but there were some
expediencies because of when we were in
the actual emergency in in the 2020
times but uh my short answer to your
question is that will take um effort
across all of the state agencies to
produce yeah I'm really only interested
in for because you're representing here
from DHHS I'm only I'm only interested
in your bucket like gopher and all of
that I know how to go about that I'm
really only interested in specifically
when it came to you guys sure so we
certainly have all that information
that's available um we would probably
need to know more from the committee in
the way in which to give that
information because it's so dense that I
I don't think it's actually fair to you
for me to just drop off like giant
stacks of paper so that's I think we
look forward to understanding what it is
you want how we can present it to you so
that it's actually read able and
understandable because it's it's STS
thank
you yeah and I think from a committee
sto it's something that we'll have to
discuss amongst ourselves um so that
there is Direction because if not um
like you said it could be we could be
all over the place so um and thank you
again I appreciate it um so
representative beler did you have
something I I was just you're good thank
you I was just going to mention on on
that I I think one of the things we'll
probably perhaps look for at some point
would be for um the persons who actually
have the expertise with the the
financial side of that at the HHS to
come here
with you know that data available to us
to to be able to help walk us through
some of that that would probably be
extremely
helpful representative
po so on topic like how we should
prioritize our work uh uh I I would
uh I I don't think we should just go in
chronological
order um I I like the idea about
topics um if anything I would go in
reverse chronological order because yeah
it's it's very important to see what
mistakes we did in 2020 with ventilation
or with masks but uh I would rather
concentrate
on Co response is still ongoing like uh
state is still uh and and there are some
questions like I don't know about V REM
s that is being used to treat it like is
it the best and safest treatment or not
or uh state is spending resources on
promotion of covid vaccine and we are
seeing that despite this promotion
vaccine is highly
unpopular so as a committee it would be
nice to see if it's actually like safe
and effective and maybe we need to
promote it better or maybe it's if it's
actually not an effective like because
it's we're currently state is currently
like heavily involved with with it so I
think like studying something
that we as a state reps can act right
now is more important than just getting
some lessons from
202 um represent PA I think that having
uh director buckton in here from
Homeland uh security um he could
technically walk us through the
beginning and to what's going on now um
he could kind of give us an overview um
and I'm not positive that he could do
that but I'm going to uh surmise that he
could probably give us an overview on
how you know a step by step on what's
gone on in the state from 2020 to now um
I also think that once we hear from him
I think you know as we go through
chronologically through topics you know
and bring in the
municipalities and talk about our state
parks we can learn about a little bit
about how that affected people and
how how that affected everything through
today so we don't have to um even though
we're going to do it somewhat
chronologically we just have to figure
out I think the big thing is is to start
with Homeland Security because
everything was directed through them so
that we have a better idea of uh as we
trickle down um because I mean had a
good point you know I never even gave it
a thought that you had to think of
guidance about driving in a plow truck
right I mean something that simple um I
never would have thought of um and for
me I was here at 4:00 a.m. on our last
session day I believe as representative
groer and leus were here also
um and how it affected the legislature
was we were hugely impacted um by the co
response um so I think there's a lot of
areas to take in so I think starting
with him and I can contact him to see
when he is
available um but I think that will help
give us a bird's eye overview of
everything and and you can ask him how
things are working today too because
it's it's like it's one subject but we
got to start at the beginning and then
we can go on to another topic I'm open
represent
beler thank you and it really just just
helped click for me um the chronological
side of this because I think it's going
to be incredibly important that as far
as any sort of final product and what
we're looking at producing here we're
going to have to produce a timeline and
what happened when um so I think there's
definitely going to have to be a
chronological component to this I I also
like maybe sometimes breaking things aut
topically but I do understand the
chronological
side
leus yeah I was thinking that perhaps we
could be topical and chronological at
the same time in that as a topic came
into important you know as a topic
cropped up then we explore that topic
and within that topic the chronology
from the beginning to now and then the
next thing that that was taken taken on
by you know that showed up do the same
thing and that gives us a sort of
logical procedure but at the same time
well it makes it logical in multiple
ways so it makes it easier to
organize um representative grto so while
representative luus was talking it me it
it came to mind
that I think starting with him with
Homeland Security is appropriate because
I do believe that what's going to happen
is it wasn't like boom everybody this
happened and everybody did the same
thing I think that there
are um
each um let's just call it each area of
responsibility regardless of what it is
whether it's DPW whether it was you know
Parks and Recreation they all man they
all
operated
independently right they all had their
own timelines because I don't think that
it was all you know everybody walking
linearly down this path because
everybody had different aspects and
different things to handle so that
starting with Homeland Security might
give us the topics that we need to
investigate because that way does that
make sense I agree wholeheartedly with
that
does what what is everyone else
thoughts so is there um any more
discussion on how we want to proceed as
a
committee representative Bela then
representative
leus thank you I was just going to ask
do we have any
um procedures in place for if we're
going to have absences that we have um
the possibility to substitute anyone or
anything like that just to make sure we
have a quorum week to week uh thank you
for that question but uh because we are
not voting on anything and we are a
special committee we do not need a
quorum and there are no substitutes
represent
leus oh I just wondered if we have any
um plans
besides our final report of somehow
getting out even if it's just posting a
link to each
week's um Facebook you
know no I didn't mean Facebook YouTube
recordings right but as so that as we're
learning the public can be learning uh
these meetings are being recorded So
they are being uh live streamed as as
we're meeting today and then there'll be
archived so anybody can go on and see
that and I do understand what you're
talking about instead of doing a final
report all at the end I think that um we
should Reserve that as we delve in just
a little bit further and uh see how the
committee wants to move forward with
reporting um we are missing uh four
folks today that I would really like to
have input from right um before we uh
make those final
decisions so do do we want to I know we
had a press release way back about that
there's this this committee was going to
happen do we want
to uh put out a press release saying
anybody who's interested these are being
recorded um I can you can you I can
reach out to the speaker's office and
see if they'd like to do that okay thank
you uh represent Pao uh yeah yeah just
wonder if uh by the end of this session
we can have some draft idea for for the
topics we want to discuss on fray Friday
23rd uh like what time period and
possibly what topics and if we inviting
anyone from executive branch for that
specific
date so I'm going to reach out to the
rest of the committee that's not here to
see if they are available uh Friday
morning the
22nd um and then I'll also reach out to
director buckton to see if he's
available because I really do believe uh
that he would be essential to the start
of this committee and I want to thank uh
Patricia Tilly uh for suggesting that so
thank you so much and uh bringing his
name before us um it's I think it's
going to be extremely
helpful represent broa I did I think
Friday is the 23rd is it not is it is it
Friday the 23rd do I have the wrong year
no I think you're right I I think I'm
completely wrong uh want to make sure
right because the 22nd was session there
so it is the 23rd the 23rd y my
apologies um the days all seem to run
together we'll modify the
recording
leus shoot now I forgot what I was going
to
ask uh let me think a moment and
remember it
okay
um any other suggestions from the
committee on what you how you think we
should be moving up represent like us
joged your memory well that was the
right question to ask um I was wondering
if we were going to have like a
committee
maybe a Google doc or something that as
we hear about that that we could have
within the committee that said what what
um what topic or what thing we'd like to
have and what people to contact somebody
may have a a topic but not know who to
contact but other people may say oh this
person this person this person or what
questions we may want you know know
somebody else may say oh that's cool I
want to know this or this and if we all
put it together it might help us
organize um who we want to invite what
we want to ask Etc I don't know um I
think I'd be cautious about doing that
because these are public
hearings um and we have to make sure
that we uh stay in uh compliance of the
91a um so I think I'd be cautious
about moving forward in that okay thank
you represent Belcher thank you just a a
newbie question that came to mind is um
as far as establishing a permanent
record of the committee if we receive
testimony written anything it just comes
down and and where does that get stored
and how would the public gain access to
it at any point in
time
go ahead I can help um so I know that if
you wanted to have any information about
about a bill let's say even if it was
not this year in the past the clerk the
clerk's office has all the files that
contain information on the bill
including the subcommittee reports and
all of the voting and all the testimony
that was filed for that bill I would
imagine that the special commissions
excuse me the special commissions are
under the same ruling so we we could
check but I believe that's how it's
done
yeah and and I I would I would agree
with that because as clerks and I
believe you're a clerk also that
everything does get filed by Bill so and
is the public can come in and ask for
any of
it yes representative Le well just as a
followup of that if if our document
our planning asking questions whatever
was public as far as reading
but not as far as input you know like if
we could does that work or not work I
believe that's something that I'm not
sure uh can you repeat that uh for our
researcher okay the question was if
we I'm just trying to figure out a way
to get input and ideas as much as
possible and so that's why I was looking
at the Google Doc if it was a public
document but not everybody as as far as
reading it but not everybody could input
in it only the committee could would
that then be okay and not be a 91a viol
because I don't want to the whole point
of this was to get information to the
public so I just want to make sure that
happens as much as possible but I also
want us to be able to
brainstorm in between each week so we
can plan who's coming and what we want
to ask them so I just trying to figure
out how to do that right
thank
you good yeah let me just real quick so
we already have access as you know like
through our legislative email to be able
to have a working document right so we
already have that uh capability
but then that could violate the 91a
piece right so that that would be an
issue so there is you know the I don't
know if we have that capability there's
a capability where literally a working
document can be viewed publicly and you
can actually see changes live and nobody
has access to going into that I just
don't know if that would be the best way
to to to to work on that because when
you're you know when you're in a draft
you're typing and you you know what I'm
saying and then someone grabs that and
says oh my gosh well this is what you
know what I'm saying so that it's hard
during committees we have work sessions
that are public and and then people can
all come together and sometimes that is
through peac mail um I love the idea I
just don't know how we could best do it
I I think um because there is no special
place that I'm aware of that it is
really not feasible uh to do that I
think that
um go ahead and represent C so I think
that having shared commissions and being
being in your position it's very
difficult but I think one of the things
that's very important is that when we
end this meeting we understand that the
date and the time of the next meeting
will be 9:00 a.m. on February 23rd so we
know we're meeting again at that time
we're going to have invited the Homeland
securities
um director M Mr buckton to come and
speak before us and then what I would
recommend Madame chair is that you have
an agenda right that we are opening the
meeting if you want to do the pledge you
put that on there and all that becomes
part of the public record so that this
all operates on a public record and I
think that
um you can speak to to the speaker's
office about how they want to do that
because different commissions do it
different
ways um and I really appreciate your
bringing that up and I think that's a
great idea um so thank you so much
um uh like I said this is uh my first
time
and because it's such a broad topic I
just really and I called it an
organizational meeting because I just
wanted to discuss how we were going to
proceed so
okay uh anybody else have anything that
uh they think we need to discuss further
or should
uh um make I'll make a motion to adjourn
for today and see everybody on the 23rd
okay
um that would be fine um again February
23rd at 9:00 a.m. with the hopes of
having director buckon here
um thank you I I don't know if we have
to make a motion
to to end our meetings I'm not sure
because we don't do that in regular
committees yeah we don't do exactly
but that's okay that's right okay um
yeah so just you just gabble it we got
to get you a gab I'm good uh but um does
that sound like a plan for everyone
February 23rd at 9:00 a.m. uh director
buckton um we'll try and get him to be
here and I think um think I think he'll
have a lot to say and give us a lot to
think about um so that we can uh make
informative decisions moving forward on
how we want to proceed
next um if represent blus and in the
meantime we can all be thinking of
questions and talking to other people to
see if they have questions absolutely
and I would encourage everyone to be
talking to uh the people in their
municipalities um and their school
districts and their citizens I mean uh
to see if there's anything pertinent
that they'd like to know from the
director so I think that would be
important um if everyone is all set uh
we will end this meeting and it is uh
1:8 I believe will
adjourn okay thank you all for
coming